hello welcome to another exciting
episode of the movie clips in centralia
review show I'm Jimmy and I'm rod and
today we were reviewing transcendence
trailer number two Jimmy is fresh to
this trailer now transcendence for those
of you who don't know is directed by a
long time Christopher Nolan
cinematographer Wally Pfister so what we
know is it will be shot on film and he's
probably gonna be like really annoying
about it the second thing is that it was
written by Jack Paglen who's written
nothing else so we like first time
screenwriters that's kind of exciting
nice right I don't kind of side or
thriller I don't like first okay well
let's find out we got Johnny Depp
Rebecca Hall I do like rebecca hall and
I do like Johnny Depp yeah I mean okay
he's a great guy I like these titles now
what we know from the first trailer now
let me just tell you the first trailer
doesn't tell us as much about the story
as this trailer does I'm going to be
honest with you Jim I liked it better
when I knew us why because the moral
find out the lesson I'm excited but I'll
tell you what's keeping me coming the
cast is amazing we got Paul Bettany
there johnny depp and and soon we'll see
good a ton Oh doubt of know we will see
a ton of people from the Nolan camp it's
like his theater troupe was like we got
an extra month let's shoot one for Wally
you know japanese text on our part of it
takes place in Japan I perhaps it does I
why do you know if there's one thing
Wally Pfister now's not a cop the
capture on film and I do mean DOM film
it's high rises yeah city strips I
really do like how everything looks um
the owners a music is a great look to it
yeah he didn't he's not the
cinematographer on this one which wonder
is like that must be a strange
relationship he's like chunky his
cinematographer and be like I know I'm
better there's like but but whoever's
his cinematographer I was doing I mean
that look it's great they were feel more
in this trailer is that how it is they
play up the kind of cyber thrower
Gomorrah cream um kind of
anti-technology groups they named the
rift soon Killian
feet once a minute killing Murphy also
from the Nolan group tells us about it
um so what we're kind of getting is a
story about joined up as a scientist
who's discovering groundbreaking
technologies and artificial intelligence
and their their groups out there who
don't like that too much now I will say
this I've been waiting for this movie to
kind of come about in a long time spent
a lot of talk as of late as technology
increases in its power and capability of
the the singularity you think we're
reaching it well you know this movie
would have you believe that it's
starting to get getting to the
saturation point where it's entering
into sort of like the public realm
mm-hmm you know mandame it manna machine
being able be merged yeah it's also kind
of echoes the same title as the
transcendent man with Ray Kurzweil it
was a documentary where he was stated
guy who recurs what I was taking like
all sorts of fells like almost like it
was like eight hundred dollars bills a
week something that that in order to
live to see the the singularity where he
could yeah merge his conscience he wants
to be part of it cuz we want even that
you want it to be done reach down well
let me ask you this question do you live
forever let me ask you this question um
if technology has gone so far why is
screen resolution so bad I don't know
well it's not it's just expensive but
he's in the computer it's prohibitively
expensive that's true I think it's more
blending that's more but but he's in the
computer as we see so now we know we're
going to be forced with a moral dilemma
which is how human can a machine be
which is a moral dilemma I've never seen
faced in the movies so there's another
there's another skyline for you this
guy's you know I was just about to
comment on that what are you bringing up
I really i just don't think that that
was a very good skyline job um like he's
they're just way too far away it's like
you gotta kind of get a shot like
almost now here's this is where we get a
lot of new stuff they're talking about
Johnny Depp's conscious being earnest
characters conscious being uploaded onto
the internet and that kind of explains
how we see all these worldly things
happening it seems like a glove traffic
that's a great shots good we're going to
talk about that in a second tale this
shot is epic you have this oil the
sludge from earlier yeah New Jersey has
never looked so beautiful mistress I
think it might take place in New York
but we don't I think it's a bird like I
said it might be globe-trotting at San
Francisco let's just look at this no one
at all the I'll go this looks like very
troubling that's very painful very
troubling anytime you go for eyes first
off but his eyes gonna go ahead one eyes
did you think that's what's happened
absolutely what is not okay at least
he's got he's got a whole bob costas
angle in three weeks that well it seems
but by the way I just want as a side
note point out bob costas I has jumped
the bridge of his nose and is now
spreading into his other we found out
that Matt Lauer is taking over for the
ailing Bob Costas that's what that one
son no way yes it's true it's true dude
he's looking bad word of your purse oh
my god your first or not that is the
breaking news we're giving you a limping
but what a pause this review and make a
breaking news video anyway so they would
they make ya hands in microwaves now ya
know they seriously he starts it looks
like he starts fixing people and making
I can't tell if it's it looks like a
robot I'm gonna be honest it looks like
a robot and there's Johnny Depp's head
kind of watching the whole thing sorry
yeah watching the whole thing now this
kind of builds up in the last one they
played this on kind of satellites in the
cornfield it kind of looks like contact
the Jodie Foster film it looks like this
is where kind of the show off the
showdown of the movie will take place
the culmination yeah and it looks like
the solar panel all these solar panels
everything for being constructive I
think I think Johnny Depp's
consciousness just requires way too much
power yeah well I'm really this is the
thing that's keeping me like really
curious is like how do we get to this
point
the movie you know well you see whoa
that was trippy yeah um you see a hint
of this it's almost I want it I'm gonna
go out on a limb and say this is not
about the singularity after Roger is
really yeah the soul so in the previous
shot there's the solar come yeah so I'm
gonna go off on a limb and say that this
is more about Nana oh yeah there is
owned you read a pan of technology in
nanobots Jimmy you noticed a lot in the
astroturf so yeah if you should get like
a little white thing and it look cuz it
looks like the sort of self-replication
yeah so we had a tailing this guy so
into film he's gonna want to be into the
real thing hard science and have some
facts behind we're gonna be dealing with
a lot a lot of different kind of
technologies going on with this movie
but me hurting her first I'm saying
nanobots nanotechnology I think I think
Jimmy's right I'm going with him I'm
gonna be honest I I think this is an ok
trailer I am still excited to see the
movie I jab it at Molly pfister very
very playfully you outfit you fist I
fish but very playfully it never it
never leads to anyone being hurt no but
I do I mean he's obviously done
tremendous work on the Nolan films and
the cast on this thing it is quite
something yeah it's got this so in fact
supply mean yeah for for what I assume
is summer fair for summer fair I think
that this will be a solid you know above
average oh no ankle sorry oh wait a mo
two words just it maybe maybe maybe
it'll kick off the summer season let's
hope so it's getting earlier and earlier
yeah um it's not a zack snyder film this
year so we got it's got to be Wally um
but I'm excited to see it I'm saying a
little less excited now with the second
trailer maybe a third trailer turn me
around we'll see if you never know let
us know what you think with the second
transcendence trailer and comment below
until next time I'm Ryan I'm Jimmy
thanks for watching